jacques victor chevallier alphonse
laissé le soin à la jeune génération
d'égrainer le nom de ses soldats c'est
le pari pris pour transmettre le devoir
de mémoire
voyez bien que ils sont nombreux ils ont
posé plein de questions ils ont imposé
avant sur le matériel sur les
équipements et est donc on porte s'est
tenue en a pas on a même ses véhicules
de la libération pour les mettre dans le
bain ce qui s'est passé
cette commémoration a débuté un peu plus
tôt dans la matinée avec déjà des
enfants très invisible aujourd'hui je
suis chef ont dit comment bonjour h f
bonjour chers faisait manger du parti ce
matin
bonjour chef et après des semaines de
préparation
aujourd'hui c'est du concret à bord de
ces véhicules d'époque ils défilent aux
côtés d'élus et devant des habitants
admiratif c'est quand même
impressionnant parce qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de monter dans un véhicule
comme ça ces brusques hausses au prince
potion c'est très brusque convoité et si
c'est bien on ressent bien ce qu'ils
sont et à l'époque
au total ils sont une cinquantaine
d'enfants a participé à cette cérémonie
patriotique
il faut qu'ils se rappellent de ce qui
se passe actuellement 1 et qui pérennise
le souvenir la commémoration s'est
terminée par le chant de la marseillaise
en souvenir de ces soldats morts pour la
liberté de ses enfants